can we talk about the latest with Jason
Sudeikis and Olivia Wilde and their new
United firm yeah this is wild after
explosive claims from their former Nanny
about their split Jason and Olivia are
speaking out they wouldn't believe the
things I've heard
the unidentified Nanny's claims Jason
laid down under Olivia's car to stop her
from going to Harry's after she made
Styles a salad with her special dressing
that a blindsided sudakis drunkenly
ranted she left us she's expletives
someone else after reading messages on
Olivia's Apple watch and that Jason
banned his kids from listening to
Harry's music
the woman gave the dailymail.com text
she says are from Jason and Olivia just
three days after split news broke Olivia
appears to write things got very
contentious with Jason last night and I
don't think I should see him until the
doctor is there the estranged exes gave
ET a rare joint statement calling these
new claims false and scurrilous
accusations adding they're part of the
ex-nanny's quote 18-month long campaign
of harassing us
last night hours after the story broke
Olivia hit the L women in Hollywood
celebration slamming the media's focus
on don't worry Darlings behind the
scenes drama you are not a woman in
Hollywood until you've begged to be
placed into a medically induced coma
until your press tour is finished
I am really I have to be honest with you
so overwhelmed by all of the supports
another star speaking out about her
split Tia Mori after divorcing her
husband of 14 years actor Corey Hardrick
he went live on IG last night still
calling Tia his wife love my kids love
my wife I love all you guys I mean the
DMS that I have gotten from so many
women that are going through the same
thing and just saying how they admire my
courage and my strength it I mean it has
just been I feel so blessed
happy early birthday you've got a
milestone birthday coming up and
Hathaway ready for the big 4-0 Ariana
Dubose and Zoe Kravitz are among the
powerful women getting their own L
covers on stands November 1st what a fun
carpet full of energy
girl power was in full effect last night
Quinta Brunson collided with Sydney
Sweeney in black leather gushing to us
about remaking Barbarella I'm really
excited to serve all the fat
oh but also just it's it's such an
iconic fun character so I'm excited for
everyone to see it have you reached out
to the Jane Fonda I can't say hi
[Music]